- All right, Kevin.
- Hey, how you doing?
- Good. Welcome back.
- Nice to be back.
- It's been, it's been a while, six
eight months like that I think.
- I think so.
- So, so what's been going
on last time and I said, you
you horrified us with the, with your arm.
- Yeah, it was.
- How's your arm today.
- It's doing a hell of a lot better.
- You wanna show me?
- Sure.
- Do I...
- Before I Get to it?
- Yeah.
- It was an Olser, Olser
take, quite a while to
heal, that you guys know,
and y'all seen the last one
how it looked before
y'all can absolutely see
that, this thing has been
doing a whole lot better.
- Oh! it's closing up.
- It's closed up now.
- It's now just a little scab.
I should have wrapped it, but I kept it.
I kept it open for you guys to see,
that I ain't been tampering with it.
It's over with.
- Do you use antibiotics
or anything like that.
- I was using antibiotics.
I'm going to get back on the antibiotics.
Because, doctors told me it was an Olser
and that it's going to
take a while to heal.
- Well, I've seen so many terrible wounds
like yours healed down
here without antibiotics,
because I think the immune systems is
on skid row or just so
incredible that no, no, no.
One's getting COVID, no, one's no
one's dying from these infections.
They're all healing up just fine.
- I actually think that
being down here actually
will strengthen your immune system.
- Absolutely.
And I absolutely think that maybe 60%
of people that actually had
COVID, and didn't even know it.
- I do you know anybody who is sick.
- I had a lot of people in
my family who had COVID.
- No mean out on the street, on a street?
- on the streets wise.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I've talked to
probably a thousand people.
No, no one knows anyone who's been
- I haven't been sick, but they have
they also have never gotten checked.
- That's true. We might
have it not knowing.
- They probably thought
they had an ordinary cold,
and not knowing that,
that was COVID.
- That's right.
- And they bit it. And that's
because the immune system is...
- Since I've been coming
down here for a year
and a half regularly, I haven't
been sick once that one's.
- Never been sick once?
- Not once.
- Wow.
- Yeah. So, so last time
you were here, you were
it was heroin that you were using?
- It was heroin, heroin.
- You your beautiful talk
on what it was like to use
heroin, but what's going on now?
- I stopped heroin around not too long
after that video, man.
It was through, through
the supporters man,
through the comments.
- The people that made
comments on your video.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know how much
love I had out there,
and support and,
and it was a hard battle,
but I kept reading and
reading and doing research
and I eventually got
get away from that area.
You get away from the
area, get away from people
you find new folks and,
and you do new things,
and you figure out what
you did before that life.
And you find that and you and
you, and you search for that.
And when you find that
that's, that's what you
that's what you go for.
And eventually you'll, you'll,
you'll you'll defeat the
you will defeat the, the, the, the demon
of the heroine you're defeated by,
for number one, you have
a physical dependence.
That's the hardest part.
That's the part that keep
people running back to heroin,
So.
so you replace it with something else?
- You can replace it
with a medical substance,
which is still a drug.
which is a methadone, sub sub texboxin.
You can self-medicate, by buying
it off the street also, but
or you can kick it cold Turkey.
And a lot of people can't get
cold Turkey by going to jail.
And how I did it was,
I used a little bit of medical help.
I took methadone, but I didn't,
I knew that nothing done
was a whole another drug
that I would have to fight.
a whole another battle.
I had to fight, after I
fight heroin with that.
So what I did was I just wanted
to beat the physical part
of the, the physical part of the heroin.
So I said, I'll use the
methadone just until can
heal from the physical part.
That's the only thing I
feel like I can, I can win.
If I can just get that part over with
and use it for about five days.
- Are you using something else?
- Not at, not at the moment.
Not at, how can I say it?
I started methadone, five
days got off of that.
I wasn't, I wasn't having
any physical withdrawals.
So I started to figure out
things that I was doing
before the heroin to get my
mind focused on something else.
Because you have a mental dependence.
Also the mental dependence,
just that's all you were think
about all day is that's all that's you
you think you ever, what did was that?
So now the mental part is just
as hard as the physical part.
And I didn't know that.
So I started studying with I'm good at.
I'm good at cutting hair.
I'm good at music, so
start, started getting back
into those things.
And that helped me get my mind
off of, the mental part.
But that was still will always be there.
You'll never forget. The, the
things that heroin had on you,
you'll never forget the rush,
you'll never forget the high,
you'll never forget
anything that kept on it.
but you never also forget
how it f... your life
up. Either
- Creativity can be a great
way to change direction.
- Yeah.
But I had a loss in my life.
- I lost something that
was dearly close to me.
He's my cousin, my first cousin
we grew up same household.
We called each other brothers and
his name is Lorenzo hall.
And that's my world.
That's my, that's my heart.
That's something I, ain't
never had, I ain't never
endured that, that pain.
I still going through this pain.
I don't think it ever
healed this, that this pain
this loss that I took in,
I wish I wish it upon no one,
but I know we all have to go
through it.
And I know that some people have worse,
worser tragic than me but,
this is my tragic and
handled it the wrong way.
I Self medicated again ,
a drug that is opiate.
They call it fentanyl.
It's a recent thing.
I been smoking it,
it's a very dangerous drug.
And I all, I know that I
shouldn't f... around with this.
So that's why I'm here
today to let you guys know
that I kinda f...de up a little bit,
and I need y'all help.
Y'all support.
And wise early, early stages of it?
I get the hell off of that
shit too. I kicked heroin ass,
I kicked this ass too.
- Yeah fentanyl is more
dangerous than heroin.
- Yes, it is.
But I am not using needles anymore.
And I will never use needles again
but I am still self
medicating because of a loss.
And I don't wanna to
use that as an excuse.
But when they say a
pain killer, heels pain
it heals all pain.
- I heard your cousin died.
- He got shot.
He got shot. you think that
you think something, I could
I always feel like something
I could have done, is
something I could have did.
if I was there, what I
could have did, what, what
what little I could have
did to help him out.
If he was with me that day,
I just figured out some kind
way to blame myself for his loss.
But, we all grown and
we all make our choices.
We make our decisions
and, he chose that life.
I didn't, I didn't give a f...
That's my, that's my brother.
And I give my life for
him and I still will.
but I can't bring him back.
I can't bring them back.
He gone, they took him away from me.
He gone and he don't, he
don't want me doing this shit
So.
- No, he wouldn't.
- So I got, I got to
make it right for him.
I got it make it right for my family.
I got my, my father, I
got my mother, my sister
and my brother.
They all got my back.
They never turned their back on me.
I love them the most,
they, my best supporters.
And.
- That's great that your family
hasn't turned it back on you.
- And I got to make it
right for them, man.
They always say, do it for yourself.
I'm definitely doing it for myself.
Dam it, I gotta do it for them too.
That's if I died, I got to die.
Trying. I'm going to do it for them.
I'm going to do it for them.
I love them.
And this is what they want.
I'm going to give them what they want.
They want their sons back.
They going to have their
sons back slowly but surely.
I just want them to know
to take a little time
but I'm getting there, I'm getting there.
I'll be there.
I cant really tell y'all
like I wanna tell y'all,
but I'm coming home,
I'll be home can y'all have me back.
- Kevin, what do you think the
most misunderstood thing is
about drug addiction?
You've had, you say you kicked heroin
and that's, that's an
incredible thing to do.
you've been through hell and back.
What, what do you think
people don't understand?
- Well, people who don't
play around with drugs
what they don't understand
is the mind alternative
a person who does play around with drugs.
- I see so many comments,
people saying, Oh
what a stupid decision,
you know, you should
you should just stop.
- It's just not that easy.
it probably did start off
as a party thing to do.
And some people, some people minds are
weaker than others.
Some people are ha had that follower
mentality also.
That's a weak mind and
a strong mind, saying
we talking about the weak
mind that the weak mind
is normally a follower of mind.
And then also what she
called a dependency.
Now y'all both had
dependency on that drug.
And that's what the mind does.
It makes you depend on the drug.
You won't be able to do shit without it.
You cant enjoy life without it.
And that's where it messes with your
Depression,
it blocks everything out.
All you want is to get high.
And it's not really getting,
I call it self medicating.
Now it's called getting well,
it's called getting fixed,
because without it, you are not.
Well, you are sick literally?
who wants to, I mean, you guys all have
we all had the flu before.
Think about having a flu.
That's what it's like being
dope, sick having the flu.
But 20 times it's worse.
Some people even on herself, man
and you don't wanna.
The only thing you know stop that is to
to get what we call a fixed.
And that's,
that's what keeps people going to
drug is just to stay well.
- How do you think this has
changed you, but you just went
through your time, addicted
to heroin and off it.
And now you're using fentanyl.
you certainly must've learned
or changed in some way.
- Cause my mind, I can say it wasn't
wasn't all the way better.
Wasn't, it wasn't strengthened enough.
And then I had a lot a lost
in my life that I used that as an excuse.
That's why I apologize
to my, to my brother
to you have used him
as the excuse to try to
alter my drug, drug
addiction with another drug.
Well I do have a strength in mind,
to know that I'm wrong
and I'm feeling that
I need to do something
about that before this get out of hand.
And that's why I came back to you,
because on my first interview,
I didn't, I didn't know
it'd go big like that.
And its kind of embarrassed about it,
I read the comments.
I didn't reply to them, but I read them.
I am going to start back replying to them,
but I read them man.
And I had so much love out there.
And I didn't know that, man, I didn't know
let so many people down.
I didn't know that people
even looked up to me,
And when I figured that out
and I seen that, man, I, I
said, man, they won't care back.
I had to do something about it.
so I, I had that part of my mind still.
So as long as I still
have that part of my mind,
I will be okay.
And I know that I can,
I can defeat this battle a hundred percent
and I'll be back in no time.
- It's great that you can
find a little motivation
in the, in the YouTube comments.
That's great.
If you can beat heroin, you
could probably be fentanyl.
- I know.
- Especially if it's
only been how many days?
- It's been about two weeks.
Yeah. So I know I can
it's I still have that part
of my mind that, that
does know that, that,
that I'm doing wrong.
- How did you shake heroin?
- I started with methadone,
where I knew
that that's also a dependency
is a drug dependency.
but you have to be on
that long enough also to,
to...
grasp that addiction to that drug.
And you'll be dependent on that
and you will have to go
through another medical,
another medical treatment
just to get off of that thing.
So I knew that maybe a
few days on methadone
just to beat the physical
dependence of heroin
I think I can, I can, I'll be okay.
I won't be addicted to the methadone.
And then my physical dependency
on the heroin and the over with.
I won't be sick.
And I felt like if I
don't be sick, dope, sick
then I wouldn't need
the dope, which is true.
But the mental part is
also, it's just as bad.
But I was able to fight that.
I was able to fight that by
finding alternatives that I like
in my life, you have to
search for them though.
You have to write it down.
You have to, you have
to figure it out, man
you have to push heroin away.
you have to make yourself
hate that mother f..
You have to hate it
You got to want to kill it.
You got the one that you got
to know is f... everything
up in your life.
And you'll beat the mental part.
But I wouldn't say beat the mental part.
Cause I think that will always be there.
But I think it
you will be able to handle
it, and be able to block it.
And that's what happened with me.
- You're replacing it with something else
creativity or
- Yes.
a new interest or something.
- That's great.
And your family is still, you're still
in touch with your family
and they're supportive.
- Yeah. Support.
Yeah. Oh yeah.
Especially my father,
man, especially my father
I love him dearly.
I'm Kevin Jr.
That's senior.
And I live up to my
name. I loved any junior.
I got that.
I am him. I'm his shadow,
And that's, that's one thing I want to fix
because
his name means something.
- Is there anything that
you, any goals you have,
anything you'd like to do with your life
if you didn't clean.
- Yeah, Yeah.
Because I want my own place for one,
I want my own place working on that.
I should be having that shortly.
- You're still living on the street.
- No, no, no, no. I'm back at home.
I'm back at home.
That was a choice of mine,
I didn't have to, but I
wanted to, I wanted to,
I didn't want to be around white folks.
I knew, I knew how I was,
I couldn't do that around them.
So I couldn't let them
see that part of me.
And that was embarrassing.
So I ran away.
- Shame is a big part of
addiction. Isn't it?
- Very apart of it
- People underestimate
i think how powerful
shame is.
Makes you reuse.
It makes you relapse.
- It makes you, it
- Makes you do all the above.
keep the cycle of alive.
- And then some people wasn't as lucky
as I was to still have
supporters, because you
can lose everything, man, you
lose, you lose everything.
You got a wife, a girlfriend
she's outta there.
she's gone.
That's number one.
And that is send somebody
further down their addiction.
And then, you eventually lose your family
and then eventually you look up,
you ain't got nobody but
the drug and the mother...
around you who do the drug.
And now how are you
going to get off of it?
You got no way off of it.
So the main thing is
ask fo supporters man.
Someone who cares, someone,
especially somebody who has been there
and who knows, what it's like.
And that's normally a sponsor.
I recommend a sponsor.
but I don't have a sponsor
but I, I recommend I do get a sponsor.
- We have a few thousand comm enters
(laughs)
- You guys are my sponsors.
- These will help you out.
- Yeah and I will be replying
back to a lot of them comments
because, you guys are the
reason why I am trying
trying. I am trying
- Awesome.
Well, Kevin, I wish you the best of luck.
- Thank you, sir.
- And I hope you kick this fentanyl.
- Thank you.
- That'd be great to get,
get your life back together.
- Yes, it will.
I would hope I'll have
further more stories to come.
- You have so much potential.
- Thank you, sir.
- All right man
- Thanks for coming back.
- We'll do, you guys have a blessed.